Валерії Сікал 24.
Вона лейтенантка строкової служби і перша військова,
яка публічно заявила про сексуальне насильство в армії.
Валерія пішла на службу до Збройних сил України понад рік тому.
В перший же день у військовій частині, що на Хмельниччині,
сталися неочікувані і так звані "службові" накази від її командира.
Він мені приказом сказав, що сідай в машину.
Я сіла і ми поїхали, я не знала місцевості.
Коли ми приїхали в будинок, то почав обнімати
і прижимати до себе, як ніби я його жінка.
Я мушу це робити? Я стою і говорю, що мені це
не подобається, що я не та, яку можна лапати і торкатись, і взагалі.
Тоді  від найгіршого врятував телефонний дзвінок.
Втім далі спроби схилити до статевих стосунків повторювались.
За словами лейтенантки, командир її військової частини,
пропонував "розважити та задобрити" не лише себе, але й інших військових.
Усним наказом вимагав роздягатись, пити алкоголь.
Тиснув й у позаробочий час, коли приходив до службової квартири Валерії.
Лейтенантка не витримала і вирішила не лише подати заяву
до Військової служби правопорядку, але й про все розповісти публічно.
Підтримав у цьому її чоловік, ветеран АТО.
Максимальне покарання для людини, яка
не має морального права бути офіцером
і керувати взагалі в ЗСУ на будь-якій посаді.
Бо він дискредитує ЗСУ.
Та Валерія - не єдина, хто має такі проблеми.
Як виявилось, за минулий рік Головним управлінням
Військової служби правопорядку у ЗСУ
зареєстровано п’ять випадків відкриття кримінальних проваджень
за статтею 154 Кримінального кодексу України -
примушування до вступу в статевий зв’язок.
Про це Deutsche Welle повідомили у міністерстві оборони.
Наразі, по цих справах триває досудове слідство.
На запитання: чи є випадки, коли кривдники у погонах
понесли відповідальність, у міноборони не відповіли.
Втім, на думку правозахисників, справи, пов’язані з сексуальним насильством,
доволі часто розпадаються саме на стадії досудового слідства.
В системі нашого законодавства всі справи важко довести до кінця.
Щодо сексуального насильства, так, важко.
Якщо говорити про професійні групи, Збройні сили України,
то моя думка, що ми будемо стикатись з протидією,
тому що при наявності війни на Сході,
честь ЗСУ, її не дуже хочеться паплюжити.
Але якщо є такі факти, то їх треба піднімати на поверхню.
Про бездіяльність слідчих каже і Валерія.
Її заяву розглянули лише через місяць, коли цей випадок набув розголосу.
Саме публічність та колективний позов - те, що може допомогти.
До Валерії вже звернулись інші військові,
які страждали від цього полковника.
Серед восьми жертв, які готові свідчити в суді, є й чоловіки.
Сам же ймовірний кривдник одного разу вже вийшов сухим з води.
У минулому проти нього відкривали кримінальне провадження
за статтею 406 Кримінального кодексу.
Це порушення статутних правил взаємовідносин між військовослужбовцями.
Він наказував, так би мовити, "лікувати" солдатів
від вживання алкоголю клізмами, процедуру
знімали на відео, а потім шантажували солдатів.
Через тиск на свідків ті від своїх показань
відмовились і справа до суду не дійшла.
Валерія сподівається, що цього разу буде інакше.
Адже йдеться не лише про одного командира, але й загалом
про честь Збройних сил України, в яку вона вірила з самого малечку.
Це віра в божество, що воєнні - святі люди,
що це дисципліна, що це порядок, режим, це щось неймовірне.
Пішла, для того щоб служити і приносити свою користь державі,
а отримала натомість великий піддих.
Нині Валерія Сікал служить в іншій військовій частині.
Її призов закінчується в травні.
Чи буде далі в лавах ЗСУ не вирішила.
Каже: все залежить і від того, як проходитиме розгляд її скарги.